nous sommes dans le métro sur la ligne
châtelet mairie des lilas banal direz
vous le métro nous l'utilisons tous les
jours nous le connaissons que trop
croyez vous depuis hier cette ligne
n'est pas tout à fait comme les autres
puisqu'elle a été choisie pour servir de
cadre à une innovation tout à l'honneur
de la ratp
vous allez voir laquelle grâce aux
images qui vont suivre
alors bagatelle contre 6,38 alors pas
trop ici ou bien je suis désolé d'être
l'otage pouvait pas venir aujourd'hui on
va pas trop
alors
c'est toi mon chéri mais tu sais je suis
en retard parce que ma voiture est en
panne alors j'ai pris le métro étude est
ce qu'il ya dans le métro maintenant et
bien le téléphone c'est formidable je me
suis est-ce que je puisse venir pour une
fois mise en plis cet après midi c'est
possible écoutez je dispose de deux
heures je suis très pris chante raconté
soir bon je vous remercie
j'arrive madame vous avez vu qu'on a
installé un téléphone dans le métro
c'est le premier oui vous trouvez ça
bien ou pas bien c'est bien c'est assez
heureux heureux
white lies bonne initiative la main et
vous allez vous en servir
questionne-t-il
pourquoi bien vous en servirez oui
pourquoi pas oui
monsieur van de putte vous êtes
directeur des services techniques du
métropolitain je crois que c'est une
grande première pour vous aujourd'hui
oui c'est une grande première c'est la
première fois que l'on installe
taxiphone public pour les u7 démarré ici
je vois cet appareil que vous avez 2
il n'a pas l'air très moderne du point
non parce que c'est un appareil
expérimental nous allons ce n'est pas
encore au public dans trois quatre jours
après ce qu on vraiment téléphoner au 22
à venir par exemple on peut téléphoner à
new york par tous les intermédiaires
bien sûr parade hier alors la récession
avaient déjà sondé phase nous allons la
voir
nous l'avions déjà en ligne
le service est maintenant ce sera
du public